welcome back Julian podcasts this
episode is brought to you by me Indies
this is overstimulating welcome back
these episodes brought to by me and
these guys picture me in these three
times softer than cotton and now they
have buddy bands which are bandanas for
your little buddy or your little pal
goes which we actually love we put them
on these guys all time go to meet undies
calm / tone and Julian get 15% off your
first pair free shipping satisfaction
guaranteed you'll love it also when you
get hungry order with post mates it is
the awesomest delivery app that brings
all your favorite food right to where
you are so you don't to go out in the
world and get it you know you just go on
the app on post mates you don't have to
talk on the phone you don't have to go
out and meet people in person if you
want to be antisocial postmates supports
you there so go download the post mates
app use code gen and Julian and you get
$100 of free delivery credit for your
first 7 days when you sign in that code
check it out we use it all the time
great service why is he liking me hmm
we've been obsessed with that that
whippet video the one about Spitfire I
love it's such a and we talked we talked
about it right yes that one kind cuz he
wants a hug give him a hug give him a
nice hug nice how did Julian well you
said hug so I'll just give him a hug I
want to give him oh hi Spitfire it's a
salmon
you're not Spitfire you just cry huh do
you want to hear a thing called Jana
thinks too much has thoughts in her
brain that any segment yeah it's do it
well I mean it's similar to me with the
PDA things and here's why I would be why
all of your segments have the same exact
jingle because it's it works oh okay
it's a jingle all right do it to us well
I did it on stream and I no one gave me
any feedback so listen all right I have
a lot of thoughts in my brain a lot of
who are dumb and I hope you can
understand them none of this is like I
don't know they're just thoughts in my
brain and outs and I'm trying to bounce
them off other people this is a
judgment-free zone this is just like
Planet Fitness except for it's nothing
like Planet Fitness just don't judge
okay you know for those of us with
headphones on that start that was
startling are you okay yes maybe take
one breath just one Julian if he just
listens to me and goes uh-huh and I
don't think he really cares I do care
what wait why is this an attack on me
I'm supporting you attack you I'm just
saying sometimes I have thoughts and I'm
like here's the thought and you're just
like I don't know what you're talking
about and I'm sick babe because it's in
your brain and I'm trying to figure it's
torture in here I I need some more
coffee maybe do that I love the way this
cake is good hmm oh boy so my first
thought what is your better have this
wheat burger because you know I usually
have about two thoughts a week that's
pretty good and then my breathe stops
working my first thought was I was
watching the show um I think it was
called like NASA's unexplained files
yes I remember it being on after I woke
up see what why are you making fun of me
I'm not I'm just saying I recall the
instance anyways so um I guess in the
70s or some point
in the like space racer you know on that
between like Russia and the United
States 60s I don't know when was that
they the United States was launching a
very expensive satellite to the moon and
their goal was to have it stay in orbit
around the moon for a very long time and
you know NASA is pretty good at math and
science generally and you know when they
spend billions of dollars on a satellite
you know they're not sending it up there
to [ __ ] blow up you know am i right
ladies and men so they sent this
satellite up to the moon and all of a
sudden it started doing a very weird
orbit and it was getting closer and
closer to the moon until it finally
crashed into the moon got it and NASA
was like [ __ ] how WTF man we are NASA
hello was there an error in my math I
don't [ __ ] think so they didn't check
their work so that's when they realized
they took a gravity map mm-hmm and oh
here we go different points of graph
unlike Earth where if you're standing on
earth in any given place we have like a
similar amount of gravity you know you
you know what it feels like to be
standing it's not like suddenly it feels
like what if you go to New York City you
can jump a little higher because all
basketball games would be played in New
York and it would be so imagine though
like because you know they have like
Mile High Stadium like in Denver where
like the ball a baseball like travels
you know foul farther a little bit
because the air is thinner it would be
like that but like crazy version of that
we're going to be more athletic and
certain like ecosystems I'd be so cool
why is he doing this I'm giving him a
nice comfy hold and he keeps trying to
worm out of it sorry I'm distracting you
go ahead so anyways I saw there's like a
bunch of if you look up gravity map of
the moon okay and there's a bunch of
them that look beautiful amazing I'm
just in awe of the people that do this
and they're like map out the ground
their brains can come up with the idea
to make a gravity map yeah
it's very impressive people how do you
even measure gravity I don't know a
thing I'm gonna I'm gonna google it okay
you google it and I'm telling you okay
so they made a gravity map of them and
it's so beautiful
and I looked at one and I don't have a
way to show you right now I guess unless
you bring it up on your iPad but it
literally looks to me like the
constellation Orion mm-hmm there's three
big red dots across the middle of the
Moon that are in that alignment you know
how Orion isn't perfectly straight
across the the one to the right goes
down a little bit yeah that's like a
little yeah and that you know if we buy
into ancient alien theory for just one
second everybody play along how the
Pyramids of Giza are aligned with Orion
and other places in the world like
Teotihuacan in Mexico like a lot of
megaliths or whatever you call them are
aligned with Orion the look of the
gravity map well quick quick insert here
measuring gravity and instrument used to
measure gravity is known as a gravimeter
I told you a thing I'm not saying it's
not a thing I'm just trying I'm trying
you don't have to keep convincing us
that you're not crazy that makes you
sound crazier I'm on board for a small
body general relativity predicts
gravitational effects indistinguishable
from the effects of acceleration but
researchers use more sophisticated
gravimeters when precise measurements
are needed when measuring the Earth's
gravitational field measurements are
made to the precision of micro goals
Micro gals to find density variations in
the rocks making up the earth several
types of gravimeters exist for making
these measurements including some that
are essentially refined versions of the
spring scale described above hmm how do
you measure on the moon there's a video
but I want to watch it it's probably a
similar situation
anyway they use the gravity meter what
am I looking up now just a picture of
the gravity map of the moon
like a look how beautiful those pictures
are I mean I'll look it up but you guys
are gonna have to look it up which one
is it it's the one that one right I mean
yeah they all look like that there's
three giant circles there's a different
picture in particular that really shows
it the one where it's kind of gray and
red but there's three huge circles that
look like the constellation of rain
mm-hmm
and so on the same in the same form okay
so crazy version of me okay was like oh
wait you know the theory that the moon
was completely made by an alien race and
placed here you know to control our
tides in our water and make the plan at
work right you know because if our
planet was terraformed by an alien race
to be perfect for human life you would
have to place a celestial body in the
perfect spot you know and that's the
moon and then when they landed on it
with the their Sat don't blink at me
fast like that one day their satellite
and it rang like a bell and everyone was
like oh my book and God would have it's
Hollow if the same alien species rate
that made or told people to build things
in an alignment with Orion what if
they're the ones responsible for making
the moon or what if they're inside the
moon and those are things that align
with the Ryan they're like t he doesn't
have a bunch of Magnus these are our
moon cities since I'm if they're they
have so much gravity they're because
they're hanging out take care of that
noise it's a good time come on it's
interesting it is interesting the
thought of aliens being inside the moon
is an interesting thought what if
they're not inside the moon what if they
just made the moon and underneath the
moon somehow there is something that
aligns with the Ryan because they're
like teehee that's where we from Beach
hmm it is interesting it looks like a
Ryan to me there's all I'm saying and I
think that's interesting
I I don't really know how to dispute
that I mean you can't tell me that
doesn't tell me those those those spots
don't look like a Ryan can't dispute
crazy you can't say that's wrong yeah I
mean so if it is say it is some sort of
reflection of the constellation Orion
right how does that work how does that
end up on a gravity map of the Moon does
it does the light bounce off of
something to do you mean like well no
I'm I don't know what I mean so I'm help
me here what is it what are the
correlation between a gravity map that
is laid out like a constellation why
would they be the same I don't know you
have no theories like why why did they
build the Pyramids of Giza in alignment
with Orion because they looked up in the
sky they're like that's the map or
something right I mean I don't know good
thing we don't know why
it just is what if there was like a
gravity map that was revealed that had
an outline of guy's face on them talking
about what would that mean does that
mean this flavortown on the moon like
what if okay so if you believe in aliens
which I feel like you should because why
not it's such a fun idea what aliens are
hella funny dude like what if they've
been mimin honest this whole time and
when we finally find out like what's
actually in like Betelgeuse or whatever
that this star the stars are we go there
someday
and it's just a [ __ ] planet full of
aliens being like gotcha yeah we've been
telling you to come here this whole time
I mean if any you [ __ ] knock-knock
joke if they're an advanced species
which they probably are way more
advanced than us then they have the
means to do all sorts of mimin what if
they just beaming they have the memes to
meme yeah baby what if it means nothing
other than just like trick do you dumb
idiots well I mean they might be bored
they might have been alive for a
thousand years and they're like what do
we do now let's just go meme on the
humans what if I think that's I mean I
don't think that's far off because and
you know what imagine if they also like
created alien plants like Guy Fieri's an
alien and he's like one of us and
and he's like yeah we've disguised this
guy as a human just a meme on you guys
here we go here's here's I actually
elide I had three thoughts week and I
already told you about this let's talk
about what if or
let's agree or dispute that there are
human NPCs okay this is good this is a
good conversation because I think that
there's no way there's not
I think there's human and pieces there
have to be human NPCs okay do you want
to explain people who don't aren't all
confirm all confirm although does show
NBC not a play on video games non-player
character so when you play a video game
and you see like the background
characters going on there like you know
pre-coated
like I walk they walk from here to there
and then they turn right and they you
know talk to you like those are NPCs so
Jenna said to media that this came from
your brain right yeah Jenna said to me
the other day what if there are human
NPCs like on earth walking and living
amongst us who are just PCs don't think
there's disease I think that's a really
interesting thought because did you ever
seen a video um I forget what video game
it was like referencing in the title but
it was like I don't know like X video
game NPC approached my car and then it's
this woman or I think it's this crazy
like woman who's yelling at this guy
will who roll down his window and it
sounds like she's rattling off these NPC
tag lines like she'll say something and
he'll respond to it and then she'll move
on to the next tag line it has nothing
to do with the first thing and by the
end of it she's rounded off these like
five completely unrelated voice lines
that would be programmed into like an
NPC and she's not interacting with him
at all I mean obviously she probably had
some problems going on and whatever but
like that's the exact type of thing that
it would look like when you expose an
NPC it would look like otherwise they're
just quietly walking around amongst us
on their pre pre-programmed paths that
they walk back and forth between I mean
I go on walks every single day and I see
a lot of the same people
I wonder how many of them or dogs are
NPCs NPC dogs they do the same route and
then when 1516 years passes they're like
okay we got to take this NPC out of
rotation and put a different one in hmm
so the humans don't notice so when you
walk up to them they do school need
something try machinery might suit you
hey call the guards okay so if there are
human NPCs right how would you go about
exposing that they're NPCs would you
have to like do some research and then
get a hunch and then figure out okay I
think that one guy who stands to the
right of that Carl's jr. up on State
Street I think that guy's an NPC and you
would go talk to him and try to figure
it out how it'll work I feel like that's
dangerous okay
I feel like trying to expose the NPC's
as dangerous it's more about the idea of
do you think it's possible and do they
exist and wouldn't they seamlessly sort
of fit in into our world you know
because if you're a person being like
I'm trying to try to figure out here at
MPC like that is terrible it's terrible
that is not productive it's rude if
someone thought I was an NPC I'd be like
yo that's what you think of me I feel
like I've also met people though that
I'm not sure our people yeah yeah mm-hmm
I know same I've had conversations
either with small talk with like
strangers or whatever where it doesn't
feel like they've had this even a
remotely similar human experience on a
very basic level than I've had there's
something off there's something not
there yeah and we live in LA so it's
possible that there you know there's
just not something there but I do think
I do have felt I felt that a lot like
the kind of person that doesn't have any
baby pictures and just showed up here
you know where your baby did you come
from dawg where are your baby picture
dawg
oh man it's such an interesting thought
for real that's what I think don't see
why not
like think about it this way you have
your morning commute right any of you
guys wherever you are in the world say
you have your morning commute you're in
your car you're on a train whatever
there are so many people on that commute
that you see every day maybe not the
same people every day but whether you're
stuck in traffic or you're on the same
subway or whatever it's just it's it's
hard to not think that some of those
people are NPCs because it makes more
sense if they are because in your brain
if they're not NPCs they're every single
person that you see which is a vast
amount of people they all have their own
thoughts in life and they're thinking
about the same things like that's what
was that thing that you talked about the
library thing that contains all of our
thoughts the Akashic record the cosmic
records the Akashic records is only so
big there has to be some NPCs to free up
some space on the Akashic record do you
know they mean it's much easier to
digest the amount of people on earth if
you think that just a chunk of them are
NPCs for me it helps me that's when you
when you first mentioned this to me I
was like holy [ __ ] this resonates with
me because sometimes I'm actually blown
away by the amount of people that exists
and it makes it easier for me to
understand that many will exist on my on
the planet that not it's not like a
coping mechanism well it is maybe it is
I just like nurses bliss right I just
like the idea that there's there's
people here that are just here they're
NPCs what if there are there is that uh
do you see the trailer for that Ryan
Reynolds movie know where he the the the
the movie is he is an NPC in like a GTA
video game he's a bank teller and every
day he like walks outside and there's
like a jet flying around the city and
there's guys being robbed and it's like
a GTA game but he's the NPC thought that
was interesting it's an interesting take
on like an action film that's my
anecdote the anecdote is now over you
can continue sick I'm glad I brought it
up I definitely don't feel like I
shouldn't brought that up no seeing your
reaction to it I don't know if there is
MPC's
I feel like we'll probably see some good
insight to that a that rhetorical
question in the comments section yeah
but don't don't go up to people and be
like hey you an MPC that's really awful
dono I don't think that's awful don't do
that
no I think there's ways to do it that's
that's nice hey you walk really you walk
well are you programmed to do that
luckily you are you walk or you just go
up to people and then you pretend you're
an NPC yeah and you say like need some
are you P an NPC - oh you know you just
start putting up flyers for NPCs
anonymous okay
hey we're NPCs society doesn't really
like us or accept that we exist want to
go talk about and then they're all
sitting around circle they're just doing
taglines need something Hey for like two
hours I used to be an adventurer like
you hey watch it do you know what time
it is yes no are you ready for my third
thought yeah wait hold on I have a
question what calm down my god sorry I'm
out of control today you know who might
be an NPC Oh a postmates speaking of
which speaking of which they're probably
not NPCs they're wonderful people wrong
no but I mean it's it's you know what if
you think of post mates like a video
game then they are NPCs and you're like
to play you're ordering food and you
watch them on the map and they're like
[ __ ] my map up I picked up the food and
they turn around general loves this
analogy anyway if you haven't used post
mates it really is like a great fun
video game that lets you get food at the
end of it like real life food so you you
browse the menus of what's local in your
area on post mates whether it's fast
food restaurants fancy restaurants
everything in between depending on what
you're in the mood for and you say oh I
want that I want that and you add it to
your menu and you click go and then the
post mate goes and grabs it for you and
then they show up at wherever you are
your work your home and they're like hey
me something
no for real they give you your food and
you say thank you and they say you're
welcome have a nice day and then you
take your food in your house and you eat
it and the whole time you're thinking
damn this this really would have changed
my life when I was a kid but instead we
had to like go out let me had to go talk
to people and I didn't like that but
there was never another option now post
mates is just making it so nice to be
able to get what you want without hassle
or stress or dealing with people and
it's great and sometimes say you order
something and it's like they've changed
the menu they'll notify you and they're
like okay you can make this change now
it's very easy you do it all within the
app it's really great we use it all time
check it out go to the App Store right
now on your phone and download the post
mates app use code Jena Julian for a
hundred dollars of free delivery credits
here first seven days of using the app
let us know how you like it as well we
use it all the time even if you need
like one ingredient not even a meal or
if you want like a side of like steamed
veggies or whatever it is you can just
order through post me check it out also
guys me undies three times softer than
cotton they have socks they have
underwear they have bra let's they have
onesies we wear our onesies all the time
Jenna wears her onesie on most podcasts
actually I would say on my company over
50% of the parties this is my my chill
spot it is great for lounging if you
like lounging or a podcast and it is
great for podcasting if you like gaming
it's great for game oh if you're a gamer
you need yourself a me undies onesie
because there's nothing more cozy and
fun and relaxing to game in doesn't get
too hot it doesn't get too hot its
breathable
you messed oh man it's just yeah other
ones these need to take note because
they really did the onesie right and
they come out with new prints for it so
it's the same three times softer than
cotton feel but new prints all the time
they have robes slippers now all these
cool new winter prints that are coming
out all the time and then they also also
have like basic beautiful bright vibrant
color prints that you can just you know
I don't want I don't want you know
designs on my underwear our onesies I
just want something plain and they can
do that for you
so right now go to me undo
calm slash Jenna Julian check it out hit
the link down below if you don't feel
like remembering that and you get 15%
off your first pair of free shipping and
a hundred percent satisfaction guarantee
you won't be disappointed so just go do
it just go do it here's what I was
saying about the MPC thing like it's a
it's a funny thing to like think and
talk about but like you just have to be
careful because sort of borders on like
I don't know the word is nihilism or
something to think that other people are
don't actually have lives or like
feelings and that's like so sick and
dangerous to think you know are you ever
saying that life someone's life doesn't
matter or yeah or the center of the
universe and then made oh yeah like that
is so dangerous and terrifying to me so
I'm like it's a funny joke to be like
that person said MPC but like to
actually think that is really sick and
dangerous that's why it was like don't
no no no no like you're you're missing
the good clarification it is just a joke
we're not yeah I think you're right it
is very it is dangerous to think that
way yeah but like it's it's a funny
thought to be like that person over
there isn't MPC you know haha teehee but
like the idea that maybe there's
non-player humans here is funny but to
actually act like that or think that I
think you talk incredibly dangerous yeah
yeah and okay yeah I got you I got you
but I like the idea of thinking about
like you know what if there's an alien
species being like let's just are some
some need something's in there you know
for some need some things and the
reality is like when you get a post me
just to kind of bring it back to that
because I was just joking they're always
so wonderful they come up to you and I
hope you have a wonderful day and they
in your food and they're nice and
they're not NPCs go ahead well what was
your third thought oh okay so my third
saw actually came a while ago when we
are watching free solo which I had like
ass problem with you had a problem with
the thought or the movie Oh everything
in general that man every I don't want
to talk about it because it really gets
me going
Honnold that's almost gone need
something there's nothing in here so I
want to be careful with the language
that I use here because I'm obviously
not my intention behind saying any of
this is not to offend anyone so I hope
you understand that so I looked up the
word savant I'm not trying to use it
wrong I'm also not trying to make anyone
upset savant syndrome is a condition in
which someone with significant mental
disabilities demonstrates certain
abilities far in excess of average the
skills at which savants excel are
generally generally related to memory
this may include rapid calculation
artistic ability map making or musical
ability usually just one special skill
as present so I think a lot of people
are familiar with the idea of a savant
mm-hmm right and you can watch videos on
YouTube of these people that make
incredible they're incredible at music
or mapmaking and all kinds of stuff like
numbers and when I watched free solo not
that he he's like a little bit socially
impaired it seems like he has said about
himself but the idea that I was thinking
of was like why couldn't someone be like
a kinetic savant why why are our bodies
like if someone is incredibly smart and
gifted you would call that a savant but
if someone is incredibly gifted with
their body why could they not be
considered a kinetic salon kinetic
savant
huh that's interesting so are you saying
that connect savants like you the term
what that means is like someone is super
physically gifted super physically
gifted yeah and that you're saying those
people exist and they're just not called
that or you think that like yeah we just
call him athlete you'd call an athlete's
fertile but like if you watch free so
low you see that this man is so much
more than an athlete and that really
treats this as his like magnum opus you
know no he's so dedicated to doing this
thing with his body
Jers him it torments him until he
actually physically doesn't like why
wouldn't someone that is so unbelievably
good with their body but you know goes
through all of that I'm again I don't
want to say kinetic savant and then have
someone be like that is so offensive
like no you can't say that like maybe we
can use a different word of a furnace
also I just want to like apologize like
it for the post main thing I was just
kind of adjusting about that I don't
want to upset anyone I know everyone you
know their work they work their jobs and
they work hard and everyone deserves
like respect you know we found that I
know
okay so what I want to in insert like in
this discussion which is maybe kind of
besides the point but a guy who
accomplishes something so incredible
like Alex Honnold did right and free
solo that is so beyond what most people
on earth can do physically but in order
to tap into accomplishing something that
great physically he is a perfect example
of someone who has fully mastered their
mind she has such an insane amount of
mental strength because you cannot go
through with something with such high
stakes and high risks and survive it let
alone you know and not die because if
you make a mistake you're dead and what
he does but continuously try to try and
try and try until you succeed at it I
mean that is the pinnacle of mental
fortitude and strength so I think it
goes hand in hand like a like a some
maybe what do we what what term are we
going to use someone who has that gift
on a physical level but then also it
ties into their mental - mmhmm right
like it's it's if maybe you saw just a
guy when you're walking down the
sidewalk he's jumping eight feet in the
air yeah that might be just a total
physical gift yeah there's no mental
strength involved he's literally just
pogo sticking up on this thing yes but
what I like so like someone who can put
their legs behind their head yes well I
okay Bacon's you might not call it you
might not call that one like this like
like this if they're these are my legs
like that yeah but the
they haven't you know put a lot of yeah
it doesn't require but it doesn't
require a fun party yeah yeah no but I
think I'm agreeing with you I think
those people should be known as
something more than just like athletic
yes especially the ones who are the the
exception of the rules the one
percenters who are able to accomplish
the most incredible things on earth yeah
because in order to do that you have to
have this mix of like insane talent but
also mental strength hmm sorry but yeah
I mean it I do think you know there are
people who are such outliers like Alex
Honnold who shouldn't just be called an
athlete who climbed the door not the Don
wall who was a was it out cap I don't
know but I hated it you need to watch
the dawn wall I don't want to watch that
to watch the day I don't want to watch
any more climbing movies
babe it's a great move I'm all set you
know why they call it the dawn wall cuz
I'm gonna throw up watching it that's
not why they call it and on wall why
because at dawn the light hits it and
that's what I think it's like the dawn
with the light at dawn hits it and then
they're like oh that's the Dom it's the
first thing the light hits or something
I don't know sick there's a good
explanation I know can I give you
another example of someone yes please
you could call a kinetic savant yeah
Floyd Mayweather isn't it the whole joke
between him and 50 cent is that Floyd
Mayweather can't read hmm and look at
this man that is so unbelievably
physically gifted hmm at what he does
specifically that you know that there
are so many complex thought processes
that go through his mind while he is
doing what he does mm-hm
and that he has all these neural
pathways that tell his body to do
exactly what he wants to do and you like
he could probably never even teach
someone how to do everything that he can
do and put them into words but his body
knows how to do them I think that that
is so incredible but that is you would
just call him a boxer like a the
greatest boxer mm-hmm I think that
there's more than that what if you you
are at
kinetic savant you have done something
so incredible with your body and in your
mind that it's unparalleled mm-hmm
that's interesting it's yet 50 cent
feels it's the need to be part of it for
not being able to read I think that's a
different story but yeah [ __ ] you dog
look who I can do with my body yeah it's
so interesting because like savants
right are capable mentally of things
that are unhuman yes like they can look
at a building and say the exact amount
of feet tall it is right that's like one
of the like things like that right thing
you know people have that gift I think
well the ones that I've seen a lot of
them are like to have to do with numbers
or like playing pieces of classical
music from memory memory is a lot of
remembering its entirety
I don't know I'm basing this off of a TV
show that I'm watching but it's like a
good existing example of a savant it's
like the brain is capable of doing these
things that are incredible Jordan Airy
yeah basic tasks in Turkana not
necessarily I mean it's like their brain
is incapable of doing other things yeah
fair enough
yeah so that's that was kind of my
question is like for a kinetic salon
they're capable of doing the exceptional
with their bodies with their bodies
being the most exceptional boxer boy
Alex Honnold 'he's like yeah i'm it's
really difficult for me to have an
interpersonal relationship yeah so
they're impaired in other ways that are
more basic yeah most people right but I
can go climb that [ __ ] wall and I
have it all mapped out in my brain so
for I can't read but he can be the best
boxer on earth yeah interesting no it's
interesting but like why are we limiting
the idea of someone being exceptional
only to their brain mm-hmm but I feel
like what about the people that are
exceptional with their bodies they're
just called super superstar athletes I
mean they're just they're they're just
called good athletes but I feel like
there's a there's a thing there mm-hmm
where you can you can be so incredibly
gifted with your body yeah I mean
there's been so many people who have
just blown the minds of everyone with
what they can do physically as an
athlete whether it's like it's not an
axe
launches them like practicing like I
think that they're truly gifted huh it's
hmm anyways welcome to Jana's three
thoughts that I had this week those are
them I'm sorry if they made you hate me
or get offended but that's what it's
been my time begin about damn well done
III truly appreciate your bracelex off
the podcaster like shut up
no they click off the podcast cuz you're
done sharing your thoughts and now
everything else is not gonna match that
that was the most exciting the podcast
will be really well I don't think so
maybe that's why they're clicking away
is all I'm saying I can hear someone
rage typing a thing we're like this is
why your thoughts stupid and you're
wrong and I hate you and I'm like it was
just a thought I'm just trying to like
put it in the world sorry I'm not trying
to offend anyone please I don't think
there's anything wrong with trying to
put your thoughts into the world
sometimes there is well as long as your
thoughts are problematic which yours are
not I mean problematic I mean just like
had thoughts you know yeah
unlike the judges on the fight last
night sorry I'm not gonna get into it
damn okay you don't play a little game I
love games I love the way this cake is
cut we got it we got I asked for
suggesting on Twitter y'all delivered
okay we're gonna play a game called just
completely switch pace yeah just have a
little fun guess the youtuber by their
Twitter bio oh I'm ready
yeah you [ __ ] hype for this [ __ ] I
thank you to everyone by the way who
suggested what we can do we there's a
few um yeah there's a lot of good
suggestions a lot of good part twos to
what we've done before so also people
want to see you pulling out of context
quotes from my videos and having me
guess what videos are from okay
okay so I went through youtuber Twitter
and I grabbed some BIOS and I'm going to
read them and see if Jenna can guess
which youtuber they are I'm ready
first one my merch store is restocked
smiley face pig emoji heart emoji that
is Shane Dawson so okay so another quick
note there was a few of these that were
such a dead giveaway that I didn't
include him and then there were a few
that were so impossible to guess like
I'm a youtuber and then that was it so
like I left out those I you know kind of
on the either side next one just a fan
account honestly that's Ricky Dillon
it's Ricky Dillon I love I love him
first of her name mother of cats queen
of the sandals is that Sofia Nygaard Wow
three four three thank you nothing all
right this one has two parts I want to
read the first part see if you know who
it is by the way they worded it and then
it for an extra hint which will probably
need I'll give you the second part web
video producer hello Pete
where did she come from okay really I'm
supposed to no no no I just wanted to
take it slow okay Pro ultimate frisbee
player is that MKV Asian yes well done
yeah he's incredible he's so athletic
yeah well okay
I didn't write the name of this person
but I know who it is copywriter for hire
ex miner I don't know who that is I'm
just gonna guess people Sarah shower
what the hell beads Dan your than the
first one thank you damn you're blowing
this by the way if you have I don't know
how long it is and the audio is like
hard to hear but like watch that video
of Sarah shower
and Brittany broski called home I was
screaming I was crying you really what
do you want you were you were howling
howling yeah yeah peepee poo-poo time
people done yeah get them some mics and
damn that's number one podcast on
podcasts in the world I'm woman enough
to know to say I don't know how though
what'd she say the solar system works
[ __ ] screaming yeah okay
Gaelic boomer Gaelic boomer mm-hmm this
is like a riddle this is a perfect one
Gaelic is that like Irish I'm not gonna
give I'm not gonna tell you otherwise
yes yes it is Irish yes it is
jacksepticeye which I recently learned
his name's not jack I'm Shawn sorry
Shawn for calling you Jack all these
years can you pick it up no pick it up
take it out pick it up okay
self-made aah what is going on makeup
magician CEO owner of blank I'm not
gonna Geoffrey start
damn it how are you doing so good spend
a lot of time on Twitter
second cutest Smosh boy I feel like this
is a trap this is Ian Hecox yes and I
disagree with that sentiment I think you
were the first cutest sorry I'm gonna
say it he cute I'm a good person
I'm just a bad [ __ ] sometimes you know
oh I have no idea do not know I do not
know we were talking about then the
other day and how we think they're in
Aries because of a certain video they
posted on Twitter that involved fire
Brett man rock oh oh my god yes [ __ ]
that videos I can we confirm or deny is
he
there's do we know I know the Olympic
way lifts that had nothing to do with
snatching them snatch form he has
incredible weightlifting formula I make
youtube videos of some pretty ugly
things I think about it as a play on
words pretty ugly things yeah I that
sounds they're pretty and ugly
okay glam and gore yes why are you a
hundred percent you're batting a
thousand still already under the second
page Jesus [ __ ] okay this is gonna get
interesting now hummus fan account
oh yeah by proxy
Sabra no what come on he's my favorite
binging with Abbas other favor I don't
we met him recently
okay there's a lot of people in the
world Julia now oh my god stop getting
upset I don't know
okay half of this I couldn't use his
better half Twitter account for this
game because it gave it away because of
a certain okay well he has a better half
that that makes videos that he's
involved in okay you love those videos I
love those videos I use a product that
they make I don't know these clues
aren't good stop doing that
it's not helping what you're doing is
not helping hollow taco oh okay
guess simply no logic no Ben yes he is
the hummus fan account whose Twitter
BIOS Thomas Vanek oh oh yeah yeah okay
next one twitch partner game controller
emoji comedy vids handshake emoji this
is Chris Moberg how how how because how
that is so basic that was a hard one
that's it
twitch partner in comedy vids that's
very like that's broad no it's not
that's Chris mile burger he's one of our
best friends dude come on
look Chris Miller whose [ __ ] Twitter
bio looks like you have his voice and
imprinted in your brain laughs he talks
like this it makes me laugh so hard all
right I think you'll get the next one to
wanna be streamer heart emoji Carina
yeah I can't believe you haven't gotten
one wrong I've gotten a lot wrong I
didn't get Ben oh yeah that was hard I
was a team effort though I should know
that but I don't
okay don't I just hit me up top baby
come on up top higher baby there you go
okay
I make tech and travel videos ready for
the emojis heart game controller dog
iPhone coffee
I just yes yeah my dude not bad for a 5
with no talent yes still batting a
thousand sit down comedian this is
France Halloween twitch partner
grandpa's favorite that swag no no
sit-down comedian sorry yeah
that's Jeff okay now this one's a long
one okay
and don't answer till the end okay this
is a great bio we should give it
attention one part chef one part
filmmaker generous dash of irreverent
YouTube personality heaping handful of
bourbon enthusiast cyclist and karaoke
singer to taste binging of babish nice
thank you sexy gorgeous and humble
chat you guys already got it I know for
a fact I already got it
I have no idea I don't know how else to
help you there okay david dobrik I knew
a Virgo that's me cam boy that's you is
you [ __ ] damn boy well-intentioned
mess listen to beep can't say that cuz
it'll give it away I don't know that's
really hard to do this I'll say
something that rhymes with the beep ok
flop boop beep boop beep what is it flop
boop beep flop poop peep say it again
stop it well was it stop making me say
flop who people listen to flop who peep
I don't know that is even hard listen to
fluff how about this flat poo peep slot
to poop Peter I love this listen to a
flat poo peep
that's it that's it right there flat poo
peep because I had the ending sounds
right now flat poo peep Julien babe it's
flats poopy
listen it's it's chill out okay it's
flat poo peep you know we're just
chatting it's flats poop heat Julie and
I have no idea
shallow what is shallow not too deep oh
my god grace Helbig
good good job you got our that was so
fun helpful are you kidding me yeah baby
okay next time
the only thing
I'm not joking about is that my life is
a joke don't know I don't know okay
mm-hmm
Morgan Adams that was that was really
like that was hard just a guy sorry I
need to start that over just the guy
being dude I don't just guy being dude I
talks like that I don't know think of
one person who might talk like that I
don't know
hey guy oh um do good in here
nice [ __ ] I almost [ __ ] out human ATM
mr. Bies yes Greg Dan Egan eyes 100%
stone not true I got plenty wrong you
have 100% lian's he left professional
screamer king of squirrels very deep
voice plays video games why'd you move
marbles so they can see how absolutely
adorable she's being like boom to the
set babe oh yeah my balls yeah
I don't know wait say it again
professional screamer king of squirrels
he's a video game youtuber deep voice
gongfu
no I don't know markiplier nice try
though my life is a joke
these are too hard I had to give you
some tough ones I don't know my life is
a joke as their Twitter buyer I do not
know that is too hot Daniel hell okay
sick don't stop grabbing her she was
doing it I know but just leave her alone
wants to do it sorry she being so cute
yeah you me I was being cute that's it
that's all I got for you you did a
hundred percent yeah but some of those
are too hard oh I'm sorry that I had to
bury up
difficulty so it wasn't just a breeze
hopefully you guys did well too if you
played along they could see her before
she was just like reaching her oh well
thank you guys for listening the podcast
we will be back next week I hope you
guys have a wonderful Valentine's Day
that is going to be what Friday I know
what day it is
but have a great Valentine's Day if you
have someone to spend it with if you
don't I hope you have a wonderful day
regardless we'll be back next week with
another podcast perhaps more games
perhaps more discussion who could know
who could even know right we're just
waiting for peeps - yeah how did you get
here are you an NPC I love you alright
guys have a great week
[Music]